[Applause]
yes
yes yes you're all you're all coming
home with me happy Wednesday everyone so
in the beginning America was a pretty
great place people banded together
created laws to keep everyone safe and
you know what it worked turns out that
if you build a country with borders a
military and a well-regulated law
enforcement Prosperity won't be far
behind but you know what comes after
that don't you compl y a false sense of
security then decline followed by
destruction because when the simplest of
Minds don't have to worry about
Barbarians at the gates they start to
develop something called luxury beliefs
you know beliefs unconnected to reality
the belief that the bad guys are
actually good guys and to disagree with
that makes us the bad guys because we're
the oppressors who keep thugs from
enjoying fun stuff like theft and
violence and drug abuse and Street
pooping also known as a walking tour of
San
Francisco But the saddest thing about
luxury beliefs is not how naive they are
it's that they can kill literally last
week in Philly a left-wing activist
named John Krueger was brutally murdered
in his own home on Twitter and in print
previously however a Krueger had
downplayed the violence gripping Philly
in so many of America's cities do I
think Krueger deserved to be murdered of
course not what happened to him is a
tragedy I hope they catch the scumbag
who did it I don't envy Philly police
who are already dealing with muggers
dealers and Eagles
fans then in Brooklyn New York another
left-wing activist and his girlfriend
happened across what is commonly known
as a New York Street crazy all of these
Street crazies are scary some of them
are more than that Ryan Carson was
stabbed to death for being at the wrong
place at the wrong time this is the part
where I might tell a joke but there's
nothing funny about Ryan Carson's death
he was likely told over the course of
his adult life that believing that some
people are dangerous crazy or just evil
that's a terrible Prejudice
unfortunately the people who sold him
that idea usually Progressive professors
they weren't around to help him that
night and if they were I doubt they
would have jumped in because liberal
professors aren't really known for their
brass balls remember the anti- police
activists who was carjacked in her own
driveway talk about convenient as far as
carjackings go it was a short walk
home but she discovered something else
about luxury beliefs they'll get your
luxury car stolen in the end Progressive
beliefs are like peacock feathers
they're all for show and they attract
Predators if you recall she posted on
Facebook the next day quote these
criminals will not win we need to take
back our city well let me translate that
for you I've been an idiot and I'm
joining the
NRA yeah
she oh you
clap slowing me
down she backs the blue now that she's
black and
blue things are getting so bad in our
cities even that Bible of luxury beliefs
the New York Times is starting to lose
Faith last week they wrote that
America's downtowns are now spiraling
from one crisis to the next as spiking
rates of homelessness drug Odes violent
crime and psychosis threatened to
overwhelm the public safety once
considered basic to the country's major
cities wow looks like there's one writer
whose BLM t-shirt didn't save him from a
mugging I hope his biggest problem now
is how to get that Biden Harris buper
sticker off his Audi
but of course some True Believers refuse
to wake up in Chattanooga a father of
three was murdered by a guy with 66
prior arrests but what's the city's
mayor calling it a senseless act of gun
violence yeah it was senseless all right
it's senseless that this Predator was
still on the street and mayor that's not
gun violence that's criminal Behavior
sanctioned by The Blind Faith of an
activist who holds political office now
we all know that in the Church of luxury
beliefs the high priests are the
Washington Dems they don't just preach
this stuff they enforce it and
unknowingly put their own lives at risk
which is one way of getting them out of
office so you think that when reality
reaches one of them their Pals might
start to question a bit Democratic
Congressman Henry qua just had a gun
shoved in his face by three Young
carjackers Who by the way remain at
large I hate that phrase remain at large
if they're so large they should be easy
to
find of course carjackings in our Na's
Capital are up 106% the only deterrent
is the
traffic when asked about it by Peter
Ducey White House Flack Karen jeanpierre
had this reassuring
response so if President Biden's
policies are helping bring Crime down
would he be comfortable with somebody
borrowing his Corvette and parking it on
the street overnight in Southeast DC I'm
not going to get into hypotheticals I'm
just going to get into the facts about
what this president has done if a member
of Congress is not safe on the streets
of the the nation's capital who
is look we're grateful and relieved that
the con congressman is unharmed we
understand what communities are going
through across the country not just in
DC there's always going to be work more
work to be
done great answers she's the Baghdad Bob
of the
Beltway she's always says there's more
work to do about everything meaning
we've done nothing about it but we'll
get to it after we paint the White House
like a rainbow so while the ignore all
this the rest of us aren't look at our
nation's retailers if you want to know
where not to move to just look where
Target is closing stores it's iron
ironic that a store called target has to
close because of
violence Seattle SF Oakland Portland New
York a closed Target is like a waved
White Flag you win scum look the Dems
can only outrun reality for so long
especially if you're built like this and
while and while the Republicans have
their faults at least they live in the
real world and it's a world that
recognizes that luxury beliefs are more
than dumb they're fatal so will things
finally change when progressives realize
what's killing them is
progressivism for the progressive filter
denies reality and instructs you to
throw caution to the wind since caution
is discriminatory and therefore racist
crossing the street to avoid a gang of
thugs that makes you a bigot you should
risk getting stabbed just to show that
you're an ally fact is we saw this ahead
of time and what did the libs
say you listen to conservative media you
would think that you know entire cities
are just you know in brawled in fights
and fires and whatever we went out had a
great dinner in New York City
tonight you know both those clowns are
gone but their legacy of misery rages on
the fact is social justice should come
with a warning label ction believing in
this tripe will only get you
murdered let's welcome tonight's guest
like his books he's often Bound in
leather author and Fox News contributor
Douglas
Murray if you need a quiet place to
think try one of his shows writer and
comedian Joe
deito taad dermis call her lifelike New
York Times bestselling author and
contributor cat
tip he's immense intense and makes a lot
of sense New York Times bestelling
author comedian and former NWA world
champion
tyus so Tyrus you've been uh wait for a
couple days so I want to talk to you
first about this because I'm sensing
that in order to be a progressive you
are not supposed to be situationally
aware you are not supposed to heed like
warning signs like maybe there's a crazy
guy coming at you you and you should
cross the street with your girlfriend
because that would be somehow an a front
to your Progressive virtue signaling
even
just you know you we talk about all the
time until you're affected the
unaffected are affected even when
they're affected they still don't get it
yeah like when I watch that video back a
man loses his life like that and there
was there was still two adult human
beings in that video mhm but no one
helped anyone yeah like throw your purse
at it throw scream yell ask for help do
something as soon as he pulled the knife
unless the volume was weird I mean I
watched it over and over again like just
shocked at the behaviors of like you
don't want to offend him yeah he's
killing somebody that you care about
yeah I don't understand that and the
guyy is still at large yeah and and you
can't ID him yeah he apparently works at
a school and the friends of the victim
are saying the murdered victim would not
want this guy in trouble a victim of a
system yes he's not a victim of a system
like they they love to say that because
the mission is falling apart and now
we're seeing the ones no matter what
happens they're going to stick with the
mission even though one of the no one
should lose their life like that I don't
care what his politics were he wouldn't
like me I wouldn't like him but the last
thing I would if I saw that going down
throw a trash can do something swing
your purse do something instead of
telling him he wouldn't have wanted he
wanted to grow old he wanted to get
married and have a family he wanted to
see he wanted to go home that night yeah
when you look at the reality of New York
Douglas you have to change to
accommodate the risks whether it makes
you look like a racist or not who gives
a well I mean it's look it's the same in
city after City I've spent most this
week in Philly and it's even worse there
I mean incalculably worse even than New
York and all these cities we just keep
allowing to just fall through the floor
and pretend that it's sort of not going
on or hope it doesn't affect us and
there's several there's several like
major problems with this and the first
one is
I'm so glad you showed the formerly
television host Chris Cuomo yeah because
he he covered himself in glory after
this attack I noticed he said on social
media that this showed why citizens
should all learn like martial arts to
defend ourselves I was
like no I don't have to become a black
belt in karate if I just want to ride
the subway yes I don't see why you've
got to be a master jiujitsu artist to go
and go out for the evening with your
girlfriend um but but the other thing is
this with weird thing and it's again
it's in city after City it's always
about the autonomy of the criminal and
very often very very disturbed people as
we can see all the time in this city as
you see it all the time in Democrat Le
cities Across America the really
Disturbed individuals who in any other
country would be in an asylum or a
hospital or a prison and always we hear
from the Dems no no no they have
autonomy they they you can't decide that
to your life these people don't have
have autonomy they're crazed they're
high on crack the public need to have
autonomy mainly the autonomy not to be
stabbed exactly a basic right it's a
basic right Joe I don't want to get
stabbed I pay taxes Joe it's not too
much to ask and I agree with Tyrus if I
were there I definitely would have swung
my
purse so you know what it's like it's
like we're in the final days of Rome but
with Wi-Fi that's what we're
experiencing and it's well at least in
Rome they had them breed in circuses we
can't even have the gluten now so they
they were ahead of us on that it's it's
ridiculous that they seem so surprised
by these things so shocked I don't
understand what their problems with the
equation because it says well we we have
these people who are violent repeat
offenders what are you going to do with
them oh we're going to keep letting them
out oh uh well you going to have a lot
of police around no we're going to
defund the police well are innocent
people allowed to defend themselves no
we're not so it's not even a plus b it's
just a over and over again it's a plus a
plus a plus a and we've even seen it
with like the the the uh representative
in in Minnesota now she's saying we've
got to take back the streets yeah from
the people you handed the streets over
to
exactly exactly it is weird though cat
you I we always talk about the when the
policy consequences finally meet the
policies Originators they'll change
their minds but it doesn't feel like
that they're going to they're just going
to deny reality and continue denying
like the friends of the victor him yeah
I I never like when I'm dead NE don't
say she would have said
this that's so true because I've said
plenty of
things just replay those
things don't make up new things yeah I I
just don't do that I mean look it's
obviously super sad uh you know I I
don't like just walk around Crown
Heights with my boyfriend but I used to
at 4:00 a.m. I used to I dated a guy in
Crown Heights and luckily for me the
worst thing that happened to me was that
guy yeah
um that's not even close um but yeah
it's it's also it's so bad also people
can't protect themselves right like if
you saw me walking around no one would
be like oh I wonder if if she has a gun
yeah I wonder if she's risking you know
years in the clink to have a felony
charge for having a weapon legally so I
mean yeah you something like that can
definitely happen and it's it's really
sad it's really really sad and it's
really really scary I had a guy today on
my block screaming words that I can't
say at people threatening to kill them
and beat them up every single like it
was absolutely unhinged and it was it
went can I ask you though were you just
kind of like that's Wednesday I'm out
there I call 911 I readings like five
times I
go there people out on the street he was
actually going after women and then it
went quiet which makes me think maybe
there was a cop there but it was
absolutely insane this is not some kind
of isolated thing this is every freaking
day every every day that's another about
the video that's so strange is that he
doesn't even acknowledge her yeah yeah
it just it it's just there's got to be
more to the story of this man's death
because it just it just watching it just
L they might have just been high they
might have been drunk I mean it just
seemed such a casual response to
somebody knifing you yeah just they're
running out of places to tell us to not
be yeah cuz they tell you don't be on
the street late at night but don't be on
the subway don't be in your car and also
don't be at home you know you yeah
that's true cuz home you know where you
can be safe though you know there won't
be anybody there to hurt you we'll be at
one of Joe DeVito
shows what a te all right why that that
was a compliment hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else